We have a lot of lane closures and roadwork for this weekend,...
...so let's get right to it.
Now, first off, the Causeway's been causing quite a headache for drivers...
...with that new elevated lane shift.
Now, the good news is those two southbound exit lanes are open.
And also, 6th street is open to make that right turn to southbound Causeway,...
...so good news for those of you who usually take the Causeway.
You still might hit some slowdowns...
...so you might want to tack on maybe 10 extra minutes...
...as you make your way across the Causeway.
Also, a full closure of the Huey P. Long bridge this weekend,...
...both Saturday and Sunday in both directions.
Now, it will close Saturday night at 9 pm until noon at Sunday.
If you're worried about delays, you can always take the Crescent City connection...
...or I-310 as an alternate route.
Also, we have a movie shoot.
Now, this will happen on Sunday right there at US-90.
It will be closed completely between Perdido St. and Poydras St.
Now, if you usually travel that area and you're worried about delays,...
...you can also take Tulane Avenue to Loyola as a detour.
I'm Lisamarie Luminais, and that's a look at your Time Saver Traffic.